(Speaking in Kankana-ey)
And I wish I can continue in my language
so that I can make no mistakes.
(Laughter)
I greet you in the language of my
Indigenous Kankana-ey Igorot ancestors.
And I acknowledge that I am
in the homelands of the Lenape people.
I am Jing,
and I come from the central mountain range
of the northern part of the Philippines.
If you've heard
of the Banaue Rice Terraces,
which is one of the wonders
of the modern world,
that is the region where I am from.
My ancestors built these terraces by hand,
as a community, through the centuries.
It is their intimate knowledge of nature
and of the way that the river flows,
the waters flow and the waters are stored,
that enables these terraces
to be irrigated
without the help of machines.
The art and science of building
and irrigating these terraces is magical.
They have been sustainably
and beautifully irrigated for centuries.
Now, my people are also known
as one of the unconquered
and uncolonized tribes
of the Cordillera Mountains.
We successfully resisted more
than 300 years of Spanish colonization
because the mountains that we nurtured
and cared for protected us in return.
Now, to be sure,
the Spanish attempted.
They heard about our gold.
So they sent many expeditions
into the mountains to mine our gold
and to tax us.
But the historical records show,
I kid you not,
members of the expedition
were sent back inevitably
and sometimes without their heads.
(Laughter)
That's right.
We are --
We were a headhunting people.
(Laughter)
And the name of my mother’s hometown,
Besao, comes from the word “buso,”
which means headhunter.
And this is why I'm always
joking around with my colleagues,
“I am a recovering headhunter.”
(Laughter)
When we drove the Spanish
out of the Philippines in the late 1800s,
they were unfortunately replaced
by a more creative colonizer:
the Americans.
And the pressure on our homelands
increased exponentially.
They wanted to mine our gold,
to dam our rivers and to log our forests
that we had cared for
at the risk of our own lives.
When they wanted to dam the Chico River,
which is the lifeblood
of the mountains where I'm from,
they were met with fierce resistance
and protests from the people.
Our burial grounds, sacred places
and amazing terraces
would have been drowned and lost forever.
And this was simply
a spiritual and cultural price
that my people were not willing to pay.
This project was funded by the World Bank.
And because of the fierce resistance
of Indigenous peoples,
they were forced to back off in the 1980s
and to put in place
an Indigenous people safeguard policy
to make sure that development aggression
doesn't happen again
in Indigenous territories without consent.
OK, so that's a new word and a big word.
(Applause)
Don’t worry, I’ll explain it. (Laughs)
So what is development aggression?
Well, development --
development is ... physical
or economic infrastructure
that's put in place in a community
to help them thrive
and reach their goals.
Like, for example,
if there is not enough affordable
housing in a community
or inadequate access to culturally
appropriate education,
development would build affordable houses
and enable access to culturally
appropriate education.
Simple.
But development
aggression is the opposite.
It is development that exploits
the resources of the community
and not for the purpose
of helping the community,
but for the developer's gain.
It is a manifestation of colonialism,
and it is a very colonial worldview
and comes from top-down decision making.
As Indigenous peoples,
we perceive it as projects imposed
without the consent of the community
and in a manner that violates our rights.
It falls within the paradigm
of overproduction,
overconsumption and accumulation
of wealth by individuals,
which has proven to be not helpful at all
for humanity and for the planet.
(Applause)
Sometimes I wonder
and I really think about,
you know, why did my ancestors,
why did my forebears
resist the dam so strongly,
usually at the cost of their own lives?
You know, the mountains are vast
and we could have moved away
from the inundated areas.
We could have gone to a different place
that was not poisoned by the mines
or that was not denuded by the logging.
But my people explain
that the struggle against the dams,
the mining and the logging
is a struggle for our identity
and for our cultural survival.
It is a struggle to make sure
that we have healthy territories
to pass on to the future generations.
And this is what I have discovered
through all my travels and interactions
with other Indigenous peoples.
This is common among Indigenous
peoples worldwide.
The notion that we hold
our lands, our waters,
our territories and our resources
not just for ourselves
but for the future generations.
Macli-ing Dulag, who is a pangat,
or a peace pact holder,
he famously said
to the government bureaucrats
who came through the territory
to push the dam,
"You asked us if we own the land
and mock us by asking,
'Where is your title?'
When we asked the meaning of your words,
you taunt us by saying,
'Where are the documents
to prove your ownership?
Titles, documents, proof of ownership.′
Such arrogance to think
that you can own the land
when we are instead owned by it.
How can you own something
that will outlive you?
Only the people own the land
because it's the people
that live forever."
As Indigenous peoples,
we own our past,
our present and our future.
Private development
for the gain of the few
and to the detriment of the community,
flies against the face of the reality
of the generational existence
of Indigenous peoples.
So development aggression
is actually an extension
of a version of capitalism
that pushes overconsumption,
overproduction
and has no regard
for the future generations.
It’s always “more is better,”
“extract as much value
and labor as you can
from the land and from the people
without caring for the future.”
So when I was younger --
Story time. (Laughs)
I grew up with my grandparents
and they always told me,
"Eat everything in your plate."
I'm sure you've heard that as well.
But there's a deeper undercurrent there.
Eat everything on your plate in order
to honor the hands that planted, nurtured,
harvested and cooked the food.
He taught me about
the concept of “inayan,”
or “do not do anything
that might harm others
or things that are bad, evil,
taboo or unethical.”
So getting more than what you need
deprives others.
Getting more food than what you can eat
deprives the hungry and dishonors
those that produced it.
He would ask me, when he sees
uneaten rice on my plate,
"Don't you hear the rice crying?"
And I would hear it crying.
So until this day,
I can't leave rice on my plate
because I always hear
the cries of the rice.
Another concept
that my relatives taught me
is (Speaking in Kankana-ey).
Literally, “Spread the good.”
Spread the good values,
the good virtues, practices,
even material things.
Another way of saying it
in my language is
(Speaking in Kankana-ey).
It means no one person
should own what is good.
It is to be shared with the community.
It is an expression of reciprocity
and honor for the collective,
and it teaches us to care
for the common good.
So these values,
reciprocity,
spirituality,
not taking more than you need,
obligation to future generations
and collective decision making,
all of these values are now finding
their way into scientific studies
and global scientific assessments
on the status of biodiversity
and ecosystem services,
climate change and land degradation.
So what we all need to do now
is what Indigenous peoples
have always known
and have always done.
As we face the negative effects
of biodiversity loss,
climate change, extreme weather events
like the flooding,
the wildfires, the droughts --
the scientists, they are slowly
moving towards the conclusion
that it is only through
Indigenous wisdom and values
and ways of caring for territory
that we see the path
towards our salvation.
The path towards our salvation
is not through more development,
it's not through more consumption
or more production.
Overconsumption, development
aggression, overproduction,
are all manifestations
of destructive colonialism
that has harmed the planet
and that has undermined
the Indigenous wisdom
that the scientists acknowledge
that we all need.
So think about it.
In spite of everything,
all the challenges we have faced,
more than 500 years of colonization,
all of the development aggression,
we are still here.
Indigenous peoples and our values
have thrived and have endured.
We have survived,
and the least we can do
is to honor this resistance
by decolonizing our structures,
decolonizing the way we think,
decolonizing our practices,
so that we can stop
the destruction of the planet.
Colonization and its tentacles
has always deprived people and planet
of the things that we naturally
and rightfully need.
It is only by decolonizing
our understanding of history
that we will understand
how we have arrived
at this planetary crisis.
And it is only through honoring
Indigenous peoples
and being inspired by the values,
providing the support and the resources
in order for Indigenous peoples
to continue to resist
development aggression and colonialism
that we can save ourselves
and save the planet.
So I invite us,
let's listen,
let's be inspired,
let us learn,
and let us support the struggles
of Indigenous peoples.
This is the only path forward.
Thank you.
(Applause)